[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tony marot alors 30 ans j'ai un bac pro
technicien d'usinage et leur
reconversion dans la restauration
entrepreneurs et créateurs de
l'entreprise
les frères métis burger
on a utilisé le levier d'être aidés par
pôle emploi qui nous a permis de garder
notre aide à l'emploi
le tout au long de la création et au fur
et à mesure que l'entreprise évolue et
que le chômage se sont arrêtés on a
commencé à se verser notre salaire tout
doux soir
notre équipe est constituée de quatre
associés mon frère un couple d'amis on a
réussi à chacun se trouvait un rôle pour
pouvoir avancer
certes plus lentement mais mieux marre
de la malbouffe
on est dans un esprit authentique ou le
fait-maison prime sur le reste
notamment avec des artistes locaux des
produits locaux et on s'inscrit dans une
démarche environnementale avec des éco
emballages créer de l'emploi pour moi ça
compte
on était tous au chômage donc on avait
besoin vraiment de 2 crée notre emploi
surtout à la réunion dans un contexte où
le chômage est quand même assez fort
chacun a des talents différents et on
avait besoin de ceux de ses différents
talents pour pouvoir créer l'entreprise
on arrive sur la deuxième année à la con
vas finir nous avons embauché
dernièrement deux personnes plus un
apprenti voilà l'équipe
on est au niveau du quartier du lavoir à
saint pierre donc c'est un quartier
peut-être un petit peu plus reculés on a
réussi à créer une entreprise qui fait
vivre actuellement six personnes plus
les emplois secondaires qui ont écrit
avec nos différents partenaires comme
notre société de livraison qui qui va
bientôt commencer le service
vous voyez l'union fait la force je
m'appelle tienne métier loïc j'ai 30 ans
et je suis co gérant de la société
électrotechnique océan indien
j'ai fait un bac pro électrotechnique en
apprentissage
puis j'ai fait dix ans dans une société
en métropole et après je suis venu
m'installer à la réunion pour créer une
théorie on s'est adressé à la chambre
des métiers qui nous a accompagné et qui
nous a aidés à monter un dossier et h
tremplin d'activités pour les jeunes
nous a permis de bénéficier d'une
subvention de 8000 euros
ça nous a permis à consolider nos fonds
pour le démarrage de l'activité est
d'investir dans plus de matériel pour
être plus performant sur le marché
électrotechnique hausse indien est une
entreprise d'électricité industrielle et
tertiaire
nous sommes au service de nos clients
professionnels de la réunion et de
l'océan indien pour les aider dans
l'efficacité énergétique c'est à dire
l'économie d'énergie pour ce faire on
installe des variateurs de vitesse ont
fait du relooking où on installe de
l'éclairage à led
on va identifier ses besoins électriques
de la on va réaliser une étude à partir
de là on va réaliser désarmant dans
notre atelier on va aller les installer
sur site faire les passages de câbles
les raccordements et la mise en service
jusqu'à la réception finale avec les
clients ont créé des cdi car
l'électricité industrielle est un métier
quand même assez spécifique
on forme les gens par rapport à notre
métier et donc on veut garder ce savoir
faire est de plus que les gens puissent
évoluer en même temps que la société
après un an et demi d'activité nous
avons pu créer huit cdi trois cdd et
nous avons quatre intérimaires
actuellement on devrait être une
vingtaine de personnes dans l'effectif
de théorie d'ici la fin 2021
chez nous on a un proverbe des hommes au
service de l'industrie la finale a eu
lieu à la villa du département
c'est là que tony marot de l'entreprise
frères métis à saint-pierre gagne dans
la catégorie création d'emplois
[Musique]
je
soler
[Musique]